this opening foreshadowing is fantastic
this rat gets lit up by some acid
leaving only his bones totally setting
up a classic Rick and Morty adventure I
was parked
I know driving around in a spaceship is
cool and all but why does Rick even need
the spaceship anymore since he regularly
transports I thought it was cool it was
also a great way to waste some time so
you could fill all 22 minutes of your
episode what is this face you're making
I mean it's pretty much the same face
Morty makes a hundred percent of the
time you tell him something it's a
combination of exhaustion and disdain
usually you ignore it but this episode
wants to set up a relationship TIFF so
now all of a sudden you're mr. sensitive
shout-out to the props guy on set who
loads the exact amount of bottles in
trash for Rick and Morty to kick out
every time they exit Herbie the space
bug if this vehicle is such a mess why
is the only trash by the door while I'm
glad to see the hyrulean economy has
taken over the universe there's no way
Rick is dumb enough to trade ten red
rupees for ten green ones the red ones
they're worth 10 times as much how will
you ever afford your flame breaker armor
okay but does anything be big crystals
and a fake on maybe fake crystals a fake
arm and the wisdom to go ahead and keep
shooting until they're all dead
also why are Peter gory and gilford
grimly even holding guns if they aren't
gonna shoot back
these tubes have no regulator to let the
carbon monoxide be exhaled and I don't
see any bubbles coming from their noses
I'm no expert but this is clearly a
suffocation machine sound does not
travel through Mountain Dew this well
and to be honest bones don't float in it
either
of course Rick could have invented some
sort of liquid modifier to give it the
density of acid that also has some sort
of acoustic transmission molecule or
something but my patience for BS tank is
running low so since when do they title
these episodes in the open this is like
The Simpsons Bart gets hit by a car
title that comes out of nowhere
[Music]
I know this extremely hilarious
conversation happened so that Rick and
Morty will have to stay down here a
little bit longer but if the idea of
dropping their buddy in the same vat of
acid is potentially a problem then why
don't they just use one of the many
other vats in the factory it's funny
they care so much but seriously this is
not a difficult decision
look I've watched the John wick movies
and those movies clearly proved that you
can't fire laser dissolve errs through
faux acid water without at least first
priming the Zenon also there is no way
that ladle was long enough to cover this
distance sometimes things are so funny
they actually need multiple sins removed
also I love this gangster character so
much I want to remove a sin but then
Rick and Morty end up murdering these
guys I really hope that when he said
even if you kill me you're a dead man
that means he'll respond in another
episode but until then he's dead forever
in that is a shame
see that wasn't that hard was it maybe
just do that the first time okay also
someone just give these guys their own
show I would watch a whole three seasons
of these gangsters followed by a
contract dispute that leads to a split
up fourth season just to watch more of
them I'm rescinding the fact that you
killed them but these guys are the best
oh that's right you weren't there for
that turns out kind of cool maybe
there's a connection there excuse me the
cool thing you did without me again the
awesome thing I haven't seen this much
fanservice callback humor since Jeremy's
college girlfriend narrated the
Prometheus school of not lap-dancing 40
seconds of logos I guess the rest of the
family went on vacation does Rick
regularly park his spaceship in the
garage there are times when this garage
has cars in it and other times there's
nothing but Rick in his lab so I'm
wondering where he keeps the spaceship
in those moments it's about execution
while this episode is mostly free from
the last two episodes psychological
self-evaluation there are still a couple
of moments in this episode that have
that hang up get over it already
a videogame but in real life you can try
stuff and then go back to your save
point yes Morty I saw it on Futurama and
now the show is having its South Park
moment where it's worried that it will
do something that another show did which
became the basis for the Simpsons
already did it you even dragged another
Matt graining show into it I may have
never noticed this before but does Rick
keep a fire extinguisher way up high on
a shelf nearly out of reach all right
remember when Morty went to school and
had normal interactions with daily life
is it a bad sign when you're having
nostalgia for the first season of a show
that's only in
season four asking for every show ever
also I don't doubt that this guy's class
is probably the worst math class you
could ever witness but I don't
understand why there is a 2+2 equation
on the board on solved nobody in this
class is having trouble with two plus
freaking two are they the show attempts
to establish here that as soon as Morty
dies he resets to his last save point
but that's not what we saw when Rick
killed him earlier and you may say
that's because Rick was the one who
pushed the button and I'll say well
doesn't that mean that it should only
reset if Rick died and you might say
it's still attached to Morty's DNA
somehow in the same person who sets it
has to reset it and then I'll say but
later Jerry resets the save point that
Morty started and you'll say it's just a
cartoon why do I care so much and I'll
say you're the one who started it man
and you'll say you're not Jeremy I don't
have to listen to you sorry I I may be
working some things out here my point is
the death reset thing is convenient and
unexplained can we carry on trumping
these examples of mundane ways to
Groundhog Day are hilarious but if he's
resetting when he misses why are there
scattered cheesy balls on the table this
turn into this long relationship segment
is exactly why I will never give up on
Rick and Morty it's carefully
constructed nuanced and confident even
though it remains irreverent and crass
sure you basically know where it's going
but it still executes sit beautifully
take your sin removal you Rascals you
earned it having said that it seems like
more tea is so Jessica obsessed that I
don't understand why he even takes an
interest in this girl he even knows he
has Jessica on the hook after he acted
all aloof around her a minute ago yes
show we know how they met we were
watching remember this is the show
briefly going into self-park there is no
way anybody knows where the tail section
of this plane is after that crash much
less created a detailed map of the
entire terrain if they did they'd have
already checked the tail of the plane I
guess the news didn't give it about the
other survivors or the other survivors
died before the helicopter could save
them look I know Jerry is dumb but I
doubt he's I can't recognize the
difference between this in the TV remote
dumb also why is Marty's bag on the side
of the couch open with the remote
control sitting neatly on top for this
type of thing to even happen so from the
time just before he met his new boo
Morty never once said a new save point
like not even accidentally due to it
from resetting cheese ball tosses to
never resetting anything cold turkey
nope also I bet you're kicking yourself
for already burning that live die repeat
episode title huh
back time travel if ant-man and the wasp
can do it I'm not interested funny
because just like ant-man an in-game you
depended on a completely random and
convenient button push to move your plot
along you just substituted falling on
your butt for a random rat and now
you're the very thing you despise also
didn't you shrink yourself in one
episode also also Rick has crazy
pop-culture knowledge for a guy who's
always going on adventures drinking and
building inventions this goes by fast so
let's sort this out what Rick seems to
be saying is that at the exact moment
Morty presses the Save button the remote
looks for parallel dimensions happening
in concurrent real-time that have the
previous save point moment just now
happening the problem is Morty was in a
relationship for several months which
means that when Jerry reset to that save
point morty traveled to universe were
all the same things that happened many
months ago in his universe just started
happening in the new universe I thought
it was impossible to think of something
more confusing convenient and messy than
time travel but congratulations and even
so this means as many times as morty
pushed the button and for all the
seconds hours days months that passed in
those moments have all actually passed
in his original dimension without
time-travel which we know Rick hates
he's been missing from his home family
for quite some time will the show ever
deal with this no does it matter garlic
bread and there was already a you and
each probable dimension so we had to
solve for that by melting the previous
Morty doesn't that leave a dimension
without a morty shouldn't they swap
dimensions how does killing one of them
even solve anything also it's not like
leaving a burning pile of Morty goo in a
dimension really changes anything it's
just a dead Morty instead of a live one
right it's a little [ __ ] prestige being
used as a verb oh this is a great
episode
the original split is still time-stamped
I can make it so those Morty's never
existed at all wait what without
time-travel I can't tell if the show
knows it's talking out of its butt or if
it actually thinks this makes sense and
that's not a good sign
you live with the consequences those
things happen somewhere but you can
merge the probable realities so that
only one Morty did them
how can you merge all these realities
when a morty died in half of them not to
mention all the ones we're doing one
thing would have meant he
have done another thing wait so you're
not even my Rick if this is a parallel
universe Rick that means there are
several other parallel universe Morty's
who all challenged their Rick's to build
the same remote right there isn't just
one more do you ask for this and all the
other parallel Morty's just went to the
room instead of challenging Rick to make
this thing let's face it there are so
many versions of morty doing this that
it would be an impossible mess to clean
up and when did this Rick figure out
that this wasn't he is Morty so did the
girl who became Morty's girlfriend
merged with all the other versions of
her who pepper sprayed him
I bet she's super confused about all
this right now of course not because
dimension portals are this shows get out
of plot jail free card also if that's
the case where and when did they enter
this reality according to my frustrated
half understanding of the concept it had
to be before he pushed the button the
first time right did he drag Morty to
another dimension while he was sleeping
either I'm not smart enough to
comprehend these complexities or this
show is shoveling so much nonsense on
top of nonsense that it hopes we don't
notice or both both could be true so
Johnny Carson is still alive and doing
his show at 95 Ed McMahon is 97 man
Johnny Carson really hated Jay Leno in
this universe did me our next guest gave
us actually very little information
besides the fact that he is impervious
to acid so we put him on the show
without even rehearsing it because
that's how talk shows in this parallel
universe in 2020 work
make sure you click that Bell icon but
clicking the little bell icon is how you
make sure you get notified every time we
release a video so click it what is this
face you're making
don't you even know who my father is
you are snob and a half and then little
Tommy flim flam's running down the hyper
loop his ass is on fire from xenon fluid
I got a rush so bad on my ass I can't
even sit down you know me I can't
complain
straight sorry boss really detailed
story to the end I'm a God your God I'm
a God
[Music]
but father I have dreams and courage and
the name of an excellent cosmetic
surgeon fear not
someday word will reach you about the
success of me jennifer Love Hewitt the
gorillas just went wild they jumped all
over his body and threw him around like
a rag doll to get to those blueberries
let me talk to you what were you would
you live